I have never read playboy before because
I grew up in the digital age so you
didn't really need magazines I just want
to apologize to my mom feel like I'm
sinning the 1960s I'm more aroused by
the prices back then 25 cents for
everything like the old-school art of so
vintage so it's so cool I don't see any
boobs yet do people actually read the
articles there are a lot of articles I
feel like that was like the old joke the
moment of truth always want to do this
damn I feel so raunchy that is just an
American Apparel ad today Oh 80s I'm
expecting hair on hair on hair the first
Bush era every picture kind of looks
like a Prince album cover
I know like women like at Walmart that
are from the 80s because they still have
their hair like this and they can't let
it go they're too poufy they look like
Pomeranians got naked it's just like a
glamour shot like it looks like
something you take at the mall that is a
jungle the sixties they're kind of like
ooh like what's there you know but in
the eighties artistic boom take a good
look America so this is the 90s I'm just
playing the theme from full house in my
head as I'm looking through this the 90s
ones just look like like my teacher like
it's weird comes with like a bio it has
our childhood photos how do you go to
your parents like hey Dad I need some
pictures of my childhood because I'm
kind of employee boy this is not up to
health code only does popcorn the 2000s
this is like when playboy needed to step
their game up cuz the internet was
around and people could get it for free
just drunk college girls lifting their
shirts up to the camera that was a thing
for like a decade and a half and now I'm
seeing an article about the two faces of
Islam good boxing theme cuz she's a
knockout
she's a racecar driver well she's a girl
who sits on race cards this is one photo
shop started to come in she's way too
smooth looking Hey look you painted her
body like this is not real this is not
real 2015 country girls
my family has a farm so I sort of grew
up on there no one dresses like this
when they're like I'm gonna go drive the
tractor if they want to sell these these
you do like hipster girls of Silver Lake
these girls are imported not if these
girls I've ever been to the south
although we did have tire swings there's
not a whole lot of racial diversity in
these Playboy's and
kind of upset by that where how people
could be in the country too you know
this is water everywhere they don't know
how to drink out of a canteen this part
is sexy but then like this part where
it's just like dripping off at the end
you're like yeah as the time went on it
was just getting just more explicit and
less tasteful not gonna read them I
don't think just cuz I mean the Internet
just interesting with these old
magazines it's like you and your friends
all looked at the same two dozen naughty
pictures I guess it's more of like a
recognizable name you know it's like
McDonald's but for for naked people
[Music]
I just want to apologize to my mom again
I'm sorry this is weird I know this is
weird for both of us because you're
gonna watch this